despite the focus being on Russia due to
the scandalous nature of the allegations
right now there is way more to
investigate about Donald Trump than just
Russia Trump should definitely be
investigated for possible collusion
between his campaign and Russia and we
should be following those investigations
but there are way more areas of
investigation that are warranted for
Donald Trump a week ago today or
yesterday Dan Alexander at Forbes broke
the story that Eric Trump Trump's son
has been lying to donors who give money
to his charity while he's been funneling
money into the Trump Organization it's a
charity for kids with cancer and that
needs to be investigated as well as many
other charitable giving related issues
with Donald Trump
Eric Trump has been evasive when
confronted about this ian jalloo who
served as a longtime membership director
at Trump national Westchester Golf
Course said to Forbes that quote in the
early years they weren't being billed
for the club the bills would just
disappear mr. Trump had a cow he flipped
he was like we're donating all of this
stuff and there's no paper trail no
credit and he went nuts he said I don't
care if it's my son or not
everybody gets billed and thus funneling
money from charitable donations through
Trump golf courses started speaking of
which Donald Trump's own charity has
acted in legal legally questionable ways
a number of times Melania Trump once
used $20,000 of charitable money from
the trunk foundation to buy a painting
of Donald Trump which is now on display
at one of trumps golf courses Trump
himself used $12,000 of charitable funds
to buy a football helmet autographed by
football player Tim Tebow many in our
audience might also remember the time
that the trunk foundation made a major
donation to Pam Bondi's attorney general
campaign in Florida the foundation hid
from the IRS and Bondi later dropped
Florida's investigation into Trump
University very sketchy Trump actually
did receive a slap on the wrist fine for
that and it goes much much further than
this possible a look at Trump's history
right forget about the possible money
laundering at a New Jersey
see no racial discrimination at Trump's
apartment buildings possible FTC
violations for stock purchases SEC
violations for financial reporting
issues the entire Trump University thing
so I think that it's important not to
ignore what's going on with Russia
but it's also important not to put all
your eggs in that basket because there
is a long history of questionable
activity from Donald Trump you know
during the transition there was a lot of
talk about if Donald Trump would be
breaking the emoluments clause by
allowing foreign dignitaries to stay at
his DC hotel that talk kind of went by
the wayside in recent months but now you
have the Attorney General's from both
Maryland and the District of Columbia
right you're pressing charges absolutely
and here is a classic just to send you
off with Donald Trump once offered a
million dollar prize if you could hit a
hole-in-one at one of his golf courses
someone actually hit a hole-in-one but
Donald Trump refused to pay him the
money because the fine print of the
contest said the hole-in-one has to be
from more than 150 yards the course was
set up so that the holes in which you
could hit a hole-in-one had the tee
boxes under a hundred and fifty yards
from the pin the guy who hit the
hole-in-one
sued and they ended up settling but
guess who paid the guy not Trump's
for-profit golf course it was Trump's
charity the Trump foundation that paid
out the money but that's disturbing it
doesn't even cover it all most difficult
to believe so anyway there's way more
here folks
than just the Russia investigation and
I've only given you a brief introduction
to that send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show I'm really
glad that taga dab the hosting
specialists are sponsoring today's
episode of the David Pakman show one of
my biggest gripes with internet hosting
companies is often not so much in terms
of the technology but in terms of the
support and that's really where taga
dabbe excel 70% of their business comes
from repeat orders or recommendations
from existing customers of theirs really
a testament to the support that they
give their customers and they currently
have
of an average Trustpilot review rating
of excellent at nine point seven out of
ten with a growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects to the cloud taga dab is
currently offering a ten british pound
free credit to all new customers signing
up for a cloud account to give you a
chance to try their service simply go to
signup tag adapt calm /td PS sign up ta
ga da be calm /p VPS